miss tilly
i'm afraid i only have a few minutes
let's get right to it
yesterday your network yarovision was
hijacked by rebels
don't shoot they called for the
liberation of so-called outcasts from
the vero labor camps is vivero produced
with slave labor
ibiro says millions of lives do you
think that those lives care where it
comes from you were imprisoned at the
age of 13 the same age as diego you
spend a lot of time with your father
she is a great teacher a lion finds calm
before the kill
fire me
i understand you were forced to endure
15 years of hard labor pruning tobacco i
hear you still have the blade
when yara becomes paradise
my methods
no one will care
you are the only survivor i watch
castillo order a whole boat of our
people shot to death
get as far away as you can from that
psychopath all of you
a revolution is not won by the fearless
it's won by the fear
welcome to libertad danny
i have a vision to rebuild paradise
a cure
viviro the most effective treatment for
cancer the world has ever seen grown
within our precious tobacco
but our paradise comes at a cost this
our enemies will never understand out
now your safety's on
you want me to kill anton castillo
kill a dictator who has raped our land
and turned our people into slaves
thinking about it
what about you you're gonna be a
hungarian legend
i'm not fearless
but i promise you one thing
i will be here
and we eat the flames
you